Nhanh trong em thử đô trên bị trái hết mình cũng dài được.
Hà Minh Giì, không biết gì và có hủ mắt tơ đi tại đại nhà của V-Cô Sất,
sự kiến hóa dết mùa hệ hàng hiểu khu chăm ha nè làm.
Bà đó mới chỉ là khu đô.
Nếu cây tây khủ tích theo sẽ được bây tây về hệ lộ trong thời gian tối,
cũng bán xem sẽ là ai.
Được tôi chức bởi đại chuyện Việt Nam, V-Cô Sất là sự kiện tâm nhà khoảng tráng.
Thưa hệ nhanh, mình không ra lễ hội ạm nhạc lúc mình.
Sống độ, dụt chàn năng lượng vì quay âm thành,
anh sáng vào cảm xúc chưa từ có.
Một đền dưới, nghe lúc chỉ thằng tâm năng hành ghi khu chăm ha nè,
đại trung tâm trên lắm, bình Nam,
một đại tựa mẹ khu kì bỏ lơ,
khuy tụt dành nghỉ sĩ hàng đầu Việt Nam.
Fó lâu kênh này để cập nhật những tích mở nhất về đại nhà khu in cao mua hệ này.